in picard episode 7 crystal ball rio
seems to break the temporal prime
directive and the regular prime
directive at the same time and is not
the first member of starfleet to do it
these are all the easter eggs you missed
in picard season 2 episode 7. episode 7
monster starts us far away from where
the previous episode left us though the
former enterprise captain is still in
his tuxedo from the europa mission gala
he's now aboard some sort of space
station and being interviewed by a
mysterious therapist played by
battlestar galactica alum james kalas
while he speaks to his patient as any
therapist would there are other clues
that something is not quite right these
irregularities include the therapist
outdated starfleet uniform in combat
along with a confusing array of relics
on the desk behind him there we see
display models from different points in
star trek history this includes the
space station k7 from the classic
episode the trouble with tribbles and
what appears to be station regular one
seen in star trek ii the wrath of khan
we also get a glimpse of an
unidentifiable starship saucer as well
as what could be the uss excelsior it
seems like these might even be
store-bought model kits but whatever the
case it's a nice trip down memory lane
and another clue as to the truth of the
scene during this therapy session picard
recalls events from his childhood and
the time he spent in the family estates
arboretum with his mother during that
period picard and his mother painted the
glass walls with elaborate scenes from
mythology which she then used to teach
him important lessons
one of the lessons taught by picard's
mother there is no better teacher than
one's enemy ultimately comes to have
great importance in the episode she also
interrupts a cosplay to give him lessons
and leadership
you must learn to lift people up in
times of grave danger
to lead them with inspiring speech
one of ricard's defining attributes is
his penchant for big inspiring speeches
whether it was to make a case in defense
of a friend in the measure of a man or
to lecture a young officer in the first
duty picard is perhaps the greatest
speech giver in star trek history q once
noted this about picard himself in the
tng episode true q
sometimes i think the only reason i come
here is to listen to these wonderful
speeches of yours
by the end of two of one it looks like
the board queen has successfully taken
over control of gerardi the queen has
wormed her way into the young
scientist's mind accessing her memories
and establishing an ability to
communicate directly through her
subconscious by manipulating jarratti
the queen gets a chemical release she
needs to take over her body and now it
seems that there is a quasi-bored queen
loose in 2024 los angeles at the start
of monsters we see the queen gerardi
hybrid striding down a major
thoroughfare we know that to survive the
queen needs a rush of endorphins and we
see her smashing a window to get that
rush however when the scene moves to the
inside of a dive bar viewers see a woman
singing with a band to entertain patrons
those in the know will recognize that
woman is none other than patrick
stewart's real-life wife singer sonny
ozell speaking with entertainment
tonight dozelle said my appearance as a
bar band singer and patrick's show is
entirely his idea when he first proposed
it to me i have to admit i was a bit
reluctant but when i learned that cbs
studios and the episode's director joe
menendez actually wanted me to sing one
of my own tunes off of my most recent
record overnight lows i couldn't resist
the opportunity since first meeting dr
teresa rios has clearly been smitten now
the feeling doesn't seem as one-sided as
it once was the rafi warned rios about
getting involved with a woman from
another century and he has tried to
resist it seems there's no holding back
the attraction between them temporal
prime directive or not with picard
experiencing a coma of sorts it's up to
talon to use a jury rigged mind meld to
enter his subconscious and attempt to
pull him out however picard still needs
help from outside which is where teresa
comes in using a 25th century medical
device rios helps her through a
procedure to stabilize picard at which
point rios reveals the truth of his
origins when teresa asks if rios is from
outer space however he responds with a
line that may sound familiar
yeah i just
work in outer space
this is a clear reference to a memorable
line in star trek for the voyage home
where captain kirk stuck in 1986 sparks
a relationship with another young doctor
from that era named jillian taylor a
biologist at a marine center
don't tell me
you're from outer space
no i'm from iowa i only work in outer
space
while taylor laughs off the comment
teresa believes rios especially after he
transports her aboard the la sirena kirk
does the same later in the voyage home
when he brings taylor aboard help save
the day
meanwhile seven of nine and rafi work on
the la sirena to locate jaradi and the
board queen they discover that the board
queen has locked them out of the ship's
systems and it's up to them to break the
lockout track down jarrati and stop a
borg takeover of the 21st century while
getting down to business rafi prepares a
couple of cups of strong coffee setting
one down on seven of nine's console
however the former borg drone keeps
working to rafi's surprise
you haven't touched your coffee you
never don't touch your coffee though
seven of nine was not one to consume
caffeinated beverages during her days in
the delta quadrant this seems like a nod
to her former star trek voyager captain
catherine janeway janeway who was a role
model for 7 of 9 was well known for her
love of coffee
coffee
the finest organic suspension ever
devised
in the voyager episode hunters janeway
even claimed that coffee was essential
for her to beat the borg so perhaps
seven of nine would be wise to take a
few sips to help her stop the board
queen from taking over jarratti and
escaping earth heading into season two
of star trek picard fans wondered if
they might finally get some answers to
one of the next generation's biggest
unresolved plot lines by exploring the
rivalry between the elory and bartender
guynin and the godlike trickster q in
the next generation episode cue who
guyan and q come face to face and it's
clear there is some history between them
this creature is not what she appears to
be she's an imp and where she goes
trouble always follows
guyan even makes a unique hand gesture
that seems to be a defensive maneuver
suggesting that her people can resist
the powers of the q continuum in
monsters fans finally get the first
piece of that puzzle when picard seeks
out the 21st century version of gainen
for helping contacting q gainen explains
that her people and the denizens of the
q continuum have been engaged in a long
and brutal cold war but have now reached
the truce she also describes more about
her people's powers including the
ability to literally bottle a moment in
time
this confirms her people are not just
familiar with the cube but have fought
them which is an intriguing new detail
in the star trek universe beyond that it
also confirms suspicions that eldorians
can defend themselves against the
godlike powers of q
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]